okay everyone we're gonna get started so
my name is Aaron standard I'm the CEO of
peda bridge I'm one of the contributors
to Akkad net and today we're gonna talk
about real-time distributed applications
with Akkad net kubernetes and dotnet
core now before I begin quick show of
hands who here has worked with Akkad net
before all right a handful of you good
this talk is intended for people who are
interested in learning about using Akkad
on net to build these types of systems
we're going to talk about today I'm so
I'm not going to assume you have that
much familiarity with it now next
question I have is who's used kubernetes
before quick show of hands there as well
okay about half the room roughly the
purpose of this talk isn't to
necessarily hold your hand and give you
step-by-step instructions and how to do
all these I'll provide you with the link
at the very end for a place we can go do
that what this talk is really about is
trying to give you a strategy for how to
build a real-time application using
technologies like akka dotnet and
kubernetes to do it so real time
applications are becoming increasingly
common in the workplace whether you work
in consumer or whether you build
enterprise applications there's lots of
different business cases like the ones
that have behind me on screen where real
time application programming is becoming
necessary and the reason why we have to
do this is because the market demands it
users want to receive notifications when
they have a bill that's passed do
enterprise users want to know what the
real-time position of each of the
vehicles and their fleet of ships or
their fleet of trucks are at any given
time in order to support these types of
business cases engineers like you have
to be able to deliver real-time software
experiences to the stakeholders in your
organization's now what makes an
application real-time well I'm going to
go ahead and break it down into three
sort of simple ingredients for you the
first time the first thing that makes an
application real-time is you have a soft
processing deadline that every single
request must fulfill
a good example is if you're building
let's say a real time threat monitoring
system or fraud monitoring system you
might be told you have to figure out
whether this transaction is legitimate
or fraudulent within 1.5 seconds of the
transaction being posted that's an
example of a soft real-time deadline if
you end up delivering it in 1.6 seconds
that's not great and that impacts the
business's throughput but it's not a
mission-critical failure like how it
would be in a hard real-time application
a hard real-time application being
something like the braking system on
your car where if you don't brake at
exactly 20 milliseconds the passenger
might die so that's the distinction
between hard and soft real-time we're
talking about soft real-time in today's
course now the next requirement that
makes your application real-time is a
non-trivial workload so for instance if
you went ahead and created let's say a
static website using github pages and
you know Jekyll or something like that
that's not a real-time application even
though it might be really fast because
the workload is completely trivial
it's stateless in fact and that's the
third criteria that usually determines
whether an application is real-time or
not it's performing stateful activity so
to give you a good example if you're
building something like a monitoring
system typically you have to keep a
sliding window of state about the power
performance of the system so you might
need to know how what's the error rate
been on this application I'm monitoring
over the past 30 minutes and what's the
error rate also been over the past
minute or so and you might want to go to
compare how the current minute compares
to the previous 30 and when there's an a
a sort of when the two curves pass each
other of the error rate you might have
to go and fire an alert see some of the
end-users who are responsible for
monitoring that application that's an
example of what a real-time application
looks like and increasingly more and
more developers are being asked to build
applications like this now the first
question I want to address that you
might have is why is statefulness a
criteria to build a real-time system
well I want to give you two
architectures on
the screen behind me here on the left
you have a traditional crud architecture
where every single time of requests
comes in we go ahead and turn that into
a database query we serialize that query
over the network we go ahead and execute
that query on our database engine we
serialized the results in the engine
send that back across the wire transform
those database end results back into a
response and then serialize that and
send that over the wire
that's what traditional crud workloads
look like well compare that to the
workload on the right well we're taking
advantage of a principle known as state
locality where all the information we
need to do the work is available
adjacent in memory to the code doing the
work so in that use case we receive the
requests we go ahead and access an
object that's already available in
memory and serve up a result right away
the performance difference between these
two systems is multiple orders of
magnitude and it's because we're
operating at a very high level of i/o so
in order to build applications that can
execute in real-time we often need to
take advantage of state locality in
order to do it that's why statefulness
is a core ingredient for building
real-time applications and the majority
of what this talk is really about is
once you start having to manage state
inside your application you as a
developer become responsible for a whole
bunch of new complexities that you
didn't become that you weren't
responsible for under the old stateless
crud model but don't worry we're gonna
offer a strategy that'll help you manage
that so the big challenges was building
real-time applications is that you're
responsible for managing the consistency
of your state this used to be something
that sequel server or cosmos DB or as
your table storage might have taken care
of for you now you have to do it because
your state and the source of truth lives
inside your application on top of that
now you're responsible for migrating
state from one node to another during
deployments during upgrades and also
during failure scenarios or maybe some
of the hardware inside your cluster
fails and you have to move that critical
state from one area of the cluster to
another
this can be a non-trivial problem
especially when you have to manage the
consistency of it too
and then finally most deployment tools
that we've you know is used historically
as developers are not equipped to deal
with state they're used to working with
stateless web servers so the idea that
you might need to replace nodes one at a
time because state needs some time to
move from node a to node B during a
deployment is not something that most
deployment engines are equipped to
handle that's why we're going to be
using kubernetes today it's one of the
very few tools that has a natural
built-in way of expressing that idea
rather easily for a developer so here's
the road map of the tools that we're
going to use how we're gonna connect
them together and how they can solve
these problems that I showed you on the
previous slide the font might be a
little small so I'm gonna go ahead and
read this for you
the first thing we need to do is create
a workable model for managing individual
entities consistently each individual
thing we're responsible for so if we're
monitoring but say we're a multi tenant
monitoring application we need to come
up with a way to monitor each tenant
inside of it individually and make sure
that all that data for each tenant is
managed consistently on its own next we
have to have a mechanism for routing
events and state to those specific
entity actors inside our system if we
have a big distributed network of nodes
that can all have state on them how can
we make sure all the state for the same
entity ends up being made consistent at
the end of the day that's the next thing
we're gonna have to address and then
we're gonna need to talk about topology
awareness inside the network how do I
know which state is on which machine and
when one machine needs to restart or be
redeployed how can I move that state
from point A to point B in a manner that
obeys our consistency principles and
after that we need to come up with a
deployment mechanism for being able to
go and deploy into these stateful
environments we don't want to go ahead
and rip all of our stateful nodes all
out at the same time and then replace
them all at once like how you might do
with a VIP swamp if you're using a web
server that would that would cause some
consistency problems if we did it that
way
so I need a deployment strategy that
allow us to go ahead and replace the
nodes one at a time providing each node
with enough time to hand over its state
to the next node that's still available
inside the network and then we need to
put everything together
acha dotnet is gonna help us with the
first three steps of the puzzle here and
that's honestly the hardest part using
akka dotnet as the building blocks to
give our programmers and our DevOps
people a workable model for managing all
of this inside our environments and
kubernetes will take care of the latter
parts kubernetes has a - a tool built
inside of it called a stateful set that
does these very things were discussing
automatically so we're going to use
docker and dotnet core to deploy our
akka donna applications and a stateful
manner using kubernetes that's the
overall goal but the first thing we're
gonna learn about is how can we go ahead
and use akka dotnet to manage these
stateful environments inside our system
so quick show of hands who's worked with
actor programming before period whether
it's Erlang akka okay
good I'd say about a third of the room
or so actors are simple standalone
entities that communicate by processing
and sending messages to each other so
this is all locally inside one process
when I'm visualizing on screen here
after one receives a message from
somewhere it could be another actor it
could also be from an external process
like a Web API or Kafka or maybe Azure
event hubs whatever you want that
message arrives into actor one and actor
one wakes up and gets scheduled on
the.net thread pool to go ahead and
process some messages under the covers
and the actor will process a burst of up
to 30 messages by default before it
yields the thread and lets another actor
take a turn behind it well actor one can
send a message to actor two and that
will cause actor two to wake up and
process some messages all this is done
asynchronously and the big implication
here is that actors when they don't have
messages to process
don't use CPU actors only do work when
there's something for them to process
inside their mailbox
and actors mailbox is just a simple
first in first out queue is all that it
is by default now this is a little bit
of actor code on screen here and
basically what you can see is an actor
is just a simple class is all that it is
there's no special infrastructure
anything else that you have to manage as
a developer you create an actor class
and then what you can do is declare
these receive methods here we can go
ahead and see I want to receive a
message of type attempt crawl whenever
an actor receives a message of that type
we will execute the method that we've
declared in there that lambda method is
the code this actor is going to run so
the actor will process a little bit of
code and then by the time it's done
processing this message it'll yield the
threads to either another actor that's
got some work to do or if this actor has
even more messages it needs to process
it'll move on to processing the next one
so we're not going to be showing by the
way a tremendous amount of code in this
presentation this is really about trying
to provide you with the roadmap for
solving this type of complex problem the
link I'm going to provide you with at
the end will give you a sort of a
step-by-step do-it-yourself tutorial you
can follow to learn how to do this on
your own now the next ingredient we need
to talk about with actors is how do we
actually send them a message the coda to
showed you is how they process them but
how do we actually get a message into
them in the first place and that's what
this unit of work called the actor
reference does the actor reference is
like a handle for talking to an actor I
go ahead and I create an actor system
initially an actor system is sort of the
environment that hosts the actors it's
what allows them to communicate with
each other it provides each actor with
the unique address and is responsible
for creating things like the actor's
mailbox that it uses for processing
messages down below that you can see we
go ahead and declare some props props is
the formula we use for starting an actor
if an actor crashes and needs to restart
it'll be recreated using the very same
props that were used to create it in the
first place now I'm a little embarrassed
to admit this but I had worked on a
cadet net for close to two years before
I figured out that the reason why this
is called props
it's because actors need props on stage
in order to act so sorry I was a
terrible joke now the last thing you'll
see in the sort of 4 the third step here
is we get an actor reference by calling
the actor of method on the actor system
and we pass in that props along with the
name for that actor now the name is
optional if you don't pass in a name
acha dinette we'll assign a random one
for you so I get that actor reference
back and now that's how I can
communicate with the underlying actor if
I want and that's what I do in the final
stage here I tell the actor this greet
message saying hey I want you to go
ahead and process this and by the way
every time you send a message to an
actor via a tell command that is always
asynchronous the message will get queued
in the actors mailbox and the actor will
get woken up later to go and process it
akkad on the actors use fired forget
messaging by default and that's what
you're seeing right there so this is
getting to the basis of how we go and
set up actors now actor references are
really important for another reason
which is that when we start with doing
networked actors using aqua dot remote
naka nut cluster actor references have a
very useful property that we're gonna
leverage to build a distributed system
and that property is called location
transparency I can tell this message to
an actor running locally inside the same
process as this actor system or I could
also tell a message to an actor running
in a remote process somewhere else
inside our data center and as a
programmer that's a hundred percent
transparent to you you don't need to
know where the actor is on the network
or necessarily what its implementation
type is all you need to know is this
actor can handle this type of message
and it'll send me zero to end responses
back based on whatever the actors state
is and other sort of factors that can
occur inside the system so location
transparency with actor references is
one of the little building blocks we can
use to build a distributed system now
the whole reason why I've been bringing
this up is we're really talking about
how we manage state inside a
I'm application well actors have some
very useful properties that make them
ideal for managing state the first
important property is that actors are
serial processors they process messages
in the order in which they were received
and processed them one at a time so if
we have a queue of three messages
sitting in our actors mailbox message
zero will get pushed into the actors
receive method that code we saw a few
slides ago the actor will go and process
that and once that received method exits
the actor will move on to processing the
next message in the mailbox message one
so one of the implications here of the
fact that actors of serial processors
means that any state that is held inside
an actor and by the way the state inside
an actor is literally just fields and
properties just like you'd have in any
other object in dotnet but the state
inside that actor can only be mutated in
a sort of single threaded you have non
concurrent fashion which means that the
actors state is always consistent with
whatever messages it's received you
don't need to have any complex
synchronization mechanisms or anything
else the actors mailbox provides the
ordering to guarantee that that state
can only be modified linearly which is
one of the highest modes of consistency
now on top of that actors are cheap
resources an actor in akka dotnet takes
about roughly 1k of memory and doesn't
use any CPU when it's not running and we
can spawn up to 50,000 actors per second
using our standard benchmarking machine
which is a d 2v2 Windows Azure VM so two
core VM so actors are cheap resources we
can afford to have many of them inside a
single process so one of the
implications of this is is that we have
an actor hierarchy which is how actors
get organized inside Aquanet you have
parent and child actors it means that we
can use this actor hierarchy inside
actors to partition our state meaning in
an environment where let's say you're
responsible for tracking annarbor
fairly large number of entities in real
time in your system at any given time
well one of the techniques you would
have probably used without something
like Aqua Net would be a giant sort of
cached in memory collection inside each
process and you might try to synchronize
that by having a copy of that cache
saved to some central location like a
Redis database and so forth and that can
get very nasty very quickly I've done it
before myself so I've been there abate
I've made I've made those same mistakes
what the Akkad net sort of actor model
allows you to do is rather than worrying
about having this sort of global mutable
state that everyone's trying to
synchronize we go ahead and concentrate
our state for every business entity
inside a single actor who has exclusive
ownership over it so one actor per
entity is sort of the standard pattern
that you see throughout a lot of actor
programming so to give you a little
historical example the last business
that I ran prior to starting peda Bridge
was a marketing automation company for
Windows app store developers called
marked up and we used Aqua Net we were
the very first production akka don''t
user we use akkad on actors to keep
track of the click streams of all the
users using our customers applications
in the store and we need to figure out
did this user qualify for a campaign
that this user might be running this app
developer might be running as soon as
the user let's say tries to buy it in
app purchase and then backs out we could
go ahead and target them and send a push
notification offering them a discount on
that very thing they're looking to buy
an order for our application to be
effective we had to be able to guarantee
that the time between that user
triggering that campaign and receiving
that notification had to be about a
second otherwise our conversion rate for
our customers would drop by about 40
percent this is a good example of a
real-time application the way we made
that work so our engineers could manage
all the complexity of doing this was we
partitioned the campaign state for every
user inside its own actor so the child
per entity pattern gives you a simple
model for being able to make sure that
every single entity inside your system
is modified in a consistent and
understandable manner this is a very
intuitive way of trying to go and manage
state inside your application partition
each individual entity into its own
actor and therefore each entity state
can be modified serially which makes
consistency a much easier thing to come
by than it is and sort of the concurrent
shared stay anything-goes universe that
we're used to operating in these are the
firt this is the first really big
lynchpin of trying to build stateful
applications now to summarize here
actors simplify stateful application
programming by doing the following four
things they process messages serially
which means that every single change to
your entity state occurs linearly that's
the first big change the second is that
all actors state is private state can
only be modified by passing immutable
messages between actors meaning that an
actors state can only change atomically
inside its own sort of private private
area if another actor wants a copy of
your state you go ahead and copy your
state into a message and send it to that
actor that actor will go ahead and get a
point-in-time snapshot of what your
state looks like now if you want to go
ahead and have an actor synchronize with
another one the way you do that would be
through using something like publish and
subscribe where every time an actor
State updates it publishes those copies
out to someone else inside the network
it's a very common pattern in akkad on
that on top of that the actor hierarchy
itself is a very useful tool for
partitioning state where each entity
gets its own actor and all those
entities can be updated concurrently if
you want to which is what helps make
actors very high throughput which is one
of the things that we need for doing
real-time applications and then finally
the most important tool is the fact that
actor references are transparent they
can be spread throughout the cluster and
many different nodes in the cluster can
all send messages to the same entity
actor which allows us to build a
consistent view of that entity in a
single place inside the cluster
now the second part of the puzzle is how
do we make sure that happens how can we
make sure all those events all get
routed to a single place inside our
cluster what's the magic trick for
pulling this off well the trick is a
couple of other modules that are part of
the academic framework namely akka dot
cluster and aqua dot persistence they're
going to be some tools we look at so
this is what an aqua dot net cluster
looks like each one of these circles
here represents an actress system that's
the sort of hosting environment we use
to go and create actors and typically in
a kubernetes environment each one of
these actor systems is going to be its
own docker container so one container
equals one process equals one actor
system that's the most granular way of
trying to manage an aqua dotnet cluster
each one of these nodes is its own actor
system and all of these nodes are
connected via TCP connections to all of
the other nodes and they're able to send
messages back and forth between each
other's actors transparently all of the
serialization and routing is handled
automatically by the akka don''t
framework itself so you as the developer
don't need to worry about whether you're
sending a message to a local actor or
remote one the framework will make that
transparent for you now in terms of what
akka dot cluster does so we're not gonna
get into a gigantic amount of detail but
to give you just enough information so
you can start researching it on your own
akka dot cluster is fundamentally about
building peer-to-peer networks in a
server-side you know back-end
environment akka dot cluster allows us
to discover new nodes automatically and
remove old nodes that need to be updated
or in the case of a sudden network
partition we can detect when a node that
was on the network becomes unavailable
and stop routing work to it until it
becomes available again we don't want to
send messages across a bridge to nowhere
right now one question you might be
asking why would I want a peer-to-peer
network in a server-side environment why
is that a remotely useful thing to me
well the answer is peer-to-peer networks
are increasingly a good tool for
to guarantee high availability inside a
distributed system the reason is I'll
move on to the next slide for just a
second here the reason why peer-to-peer
networks are helpful is they're
decentralized there's not a single
master that dictates what the total
state of the system is at any given time
rather that state is distributed across
the edges of the system in a
peer-to-peer network and one of the
profound implications of this is is that
this helps us avoid single points of
failure and single points of bottleneck
if one node goes down and our
peer-to-peer network we lose some of the
bandwidth and capacity that node had but
it doesn't compromise the total
availability of the system we're able to
stay available and continue processing
requests so that's why we want to use a
peer-to-peer network here it's one of
the tools that can guarantee that we can
go and scale out in a linear fashion if
you double the number of nodes in a
peer-to-peer network you double its
capacity right that's not necessarily
true in client-server networks where the
server that's sort of the root
dependency typically your database
server can't scale linearly that's
always the bottleneck that constrains
the growth of the system this is not the
case in a stateful peer-to-peer
application like the type you can build
with a cannot cluster the last thing I
wanted to mention is that couple of the
other important features are connect
cluster has one of one feature that's
quite useful is called rolls these are
tags or labels you can apply to each
node inside your cluster this allows you
to build a heterogeneous application
where there can be different services
that all work cooperatively together
inside the peer-to-peer network that do
different things the sample application
that I'm going to try to get to has a
total of four different services running
inside of it they'll all perform
different workloads fundamentally and
they're all able to work cooperatively
together and they might even be written
by different teams within your
organization as long as they all have
standardized messaging contracts that
can work so that's what roles are all
about and the last feature that akka dot
cluster itself ships is what's called a
clustered router which is an actor that
can detect when new nodes join the
cluster and when
old nodes leave or one nodes become
temporarily unavailable and can route
messages to the appropriate party based
on who's inside the network right now
and that's the tool we're going to look
at today for doing state distribution
inside our system now the way it cluster
forms I'm going to go ahead and skip
through some of this real quickly
because and the interest of time here
but the way it cluster forms is you have
at least two nodes that are exist on
sort of a well known address maybe even
a static address inside your network and
they act as the seed nodes that help
form the basis of your cluster well one
the rest of the nodes start up inside a
connect cluster they're all configured
to go ahead and communicate with those
seeds and seed nodes initially and after
a period of time every node in the
cluster will be connected directly to
every other node this forms a specific
type of peer-to-peer network known as a
mesh network where every node is
directly connected to every other node
this means that nodes don't have to
worry about doing a traffic routing and
load balancing because they all have
their own connection to each party it
also means that failure detection inside
a mesh network is pretty close to
real-time if one node crashes every
other node knows that their connection
to it was broken within a very brief
window of time here so since we're
interested in building real time
applications being notified immediately
about failures inside our system is
quite important that's why a mesh
network design like this works pretty
well in our favor now we're going
through a lot of concepts so I'm gonna
put these slides online and be available
for questions afterwards but the next
thing I want to introduce is probably
one of the most important concepts and
not just a cadet but distributed
programming in general which is how can
you partition and distribute state in an
intelligible fashion inside a network
like the types you can build with a
Canuck cluster the technique we're going
to look at primarily is known as
consistent hash distributions or an
octet we're going to use a specific type
of router called a consistent hashing
router this is an actor that uses a
consistent hashing strategy to figure
all the entities for a specific hash key
should all go to the same place inside
the network that way I can build a
consistent picture of what that entity
state should look like so we're gonna
use that but some other techniques that
are available inside acha dot cluster
for distributing state I'll collect
cluster starting is probably the tool
that most people use in production it's
a little bit more intelligent than a
consistent hash router but it uses the
same math under the covers and then
finally if you saw Bart OSHA's talk a
little bit earlier today on CR DTS there
is another module akka dotnet for doing
in memory replication called distributed
data so bartosz gave his talk a little
earlier today he's here in the front row
if you want to ask him about it but
that's yet another way of distributing
state inside akka net that we're not
going to touch on today our strategy for
trying to guarantee consistency inside a
naka dot cluster application is we could
try to guarantee there is exactly at
most one instance of an entity actor
insider system at any given time if we
started allowing let's say at least one
instance of an actor where if a node
went down inside the network or assuming
if a node became unavailable inside the
network and we immediately tried to move
that state to another node without
knowing if that process had shut down
that would violate some of our
consistency rules and you'll see an
example of that in just a minute but
this is our strategy for trying to
manage state consistently inside our
system now the way a clustered router
works in alkyd net is let's suppose we
have four nodes that are all identical
they all run the exact same code they're
all going to work cooperatively together
to try to give us some scale and some
fault tolerance to solve these sort of
real-time state processing problems that
we have we're going to create a router
on one of these nodes 1 nodes 2 and 4
are able to connect to node 1 and form a
cluster that router will begin adding
entries into its routing table for each
one of those nodes which will allow us
to begin distributing messages to either
one of those nodes so as soon as that
router a node number one because a
router is just an actor as soon as it
receives a message
it'll be able to going forward that
message to the appropriate node based on
its routing strategy that strategy could
be a round-robin strategy it could be a
broadcast strategy where every node gets
every message but the one we're going to
focus on today is called a consistent
hashing strategy and by the way if node
four becomes unavailable the router will
typically stop sending messages to that
node until it comes back again now what
I really wanted to talk about in the
context of distributing state is a
mathematical technique called consistent
hashing this is used in databases for
partitioning keys it's used in caches
like M cache D for being able to make
sure that each cached object is unique
inside the system and we use it inside
acha dotnet both inside clustered
consistent hashing routers and inside
cluster sharding the way this technique
works is you take a consistent hashing
function so md5 and murmur three are
examples of them and what makes the hash
function consistent is the fact that the
same input always produces the same
output each time so that means every
node in the cluster when they hash the
same key always get the same output back
now you might be thinking doesn't every
hash function do this and the answer is
no a good example of a hash function
that does not do this is anytime you
call get hash code on object and net
those hash codes are all slightly
randomized from process to process and
that's in order to prevent a specific
type of attack called a hash code
prediction attack so that's why hash
codes from you know the normal dotnet
base class aren't reliable for doing
this type of distribution we have to go
and run our keys through something like
a md5 or murmur three algorithm instead
now the other thing that makes
consistent hashing functions interesting
is their hash range can be plotted
linearly in a circle in this case a
clockwise circle we're going to assume
that our hash output is an unsigned long
integer for the sake of making it
simpler and so that means we have two to
the 64 possible hash values that can
ever be output from this function well I
can go ahead and carve up that hash ring
into pie slices we're node1 owns the
first pie slice no two owns the second
node 3 owns the third and you get the
idea right we can read Avaya however
many times we need depending upon how
many nodes there are inside our network
that can host this type of entity so the
big implication here is whoops sorry
about that
the big implication here is that I go
ahead and send two messages to my
consistent hash router for both both of
them have the hash key aryn as their as
their primary as their key value well
that means that I know that those hashed
values are both here to go to node
number one and if I go an input a
totally different hash key let's say a
grid of some kind I know that that
message will be routed to node number
two instead of node number one so inside
our network if I go ahead and send a
message of type errand to one of my
consistent hash routers I know that that
actor that owns that entity exists on
node number three because that's where
the hash value was was placed on the
ring so I'm gonna go ahead and route
that message to node number three if
node number four receives another hash
key another message with the hash key of
Erin I'm gonna route that to the exact
same destination actor on the other side
of the network and so on you get the
idea what this means is is that we're
able to form a complete picture of what
this entity state must look like inside
this actor running on node number three
inside our network this helps us form
that consistent view we need in order to
build these real-time applications that
can work effectively so that's the state
distribution piece now we need to worry
about one of the other complexities that
state introduces inside our application
which is state has to be moved when the
topology of our cluster changes so let's
say we have these two web nodes talking
to a business node under the covers and
we need to upgrade this node
an updated version of our application
well what's gonna happen is we might
bring that new note online and we have
to suddenly move that state from all the
actors that were running on the old node
onto the new one and this is where some
tricky consistency issues can happen how
do I make sure the data that's our that
our entities saved on the previous node
properly gets moved on to the firaon to
the new node we just started up how can
I make sure that happens well the most
common technique for doing this is using
a technique called akkad uh persistence
which uses event sourcing under the
covers the way this works is as an actor
processes events that cause it to change
its state we persist those events or we
can even persist a snapshot of what our
state looks like to a durable store like
a database or a cloud file system or you
know any any number of other sort of
durable mechanisms 99% of the time it's
going to be a database though what this
means is that what an actor has moved
from one node in our network to another
that actor can go ahead and begin
replaying the events that persisted and
it can use that to rebuild its state and
Akkad uh persistence is able to
guarantee by the way that that actor
will fully recover its previous state
before it can begin processing any new
messages that's how we can make sure
that that data is consistent from one
node to another inside the network now
if I'm using a clustered router as my
primary tool for distributing state
here's what this whole picture put
together looks like inside ANCA dot
cluster so we have a clustered
consistent hash router on one node
routing events to a stateful service
that's operating on another node inside
the network well what will end up
happening is if I bring a new node
online and I go ahead and I distribute
messages still to this router and that
router gets a notification that this new
node is available where I'm going to go
ahead and do is say ok I want to begin
routing messages for some of those
entities
so this new node that is now here ivory
divided that hash range in half well
what'll end up happening is will
recreate this new entity actor
underneath the route key that's on the
other end of the router and it'll begin
recovering its state from the database
and once it's done that it'll go ahead
and start updating its state and
processing events just like how the old
incarnation of that actor did which we
can now safely pull offline now you
might be wondering if you take a look at
this graph if I go back to this stage
this looks a little dangerous doesn't it
we have an actor recovering its state
while there's another incarnation of
that same end of the actor running in a
different place in the network this is
effectively a type of potential
consistency problem known as a split
brain this is what acha dot cluster
sharding consult can help solve it's
able to guarantee that before we create
the new actor we passivate and terminate
the old one before moving it onto a new
node now this talk already introduces
enough new concepts so I decided to
leave cluster sharding as homework for
you to explore on your own but it
essentially uses the same type of math
and distribution mechanism it's just
able to buffer any messages that would
have gone to the new entity actor until
the old entity actor has been terminated
that's why cluster sharding is the
preferred mechanism for doing this in
production I'll go ahead and move on
here now these are all the different
pieces that you as the application
developer need to be concerned with
while you're working with akkad annette
kubernetes is the next piece of the
puzzle and it won't take too long
but we're to go ahead and talk about how
we can use that to do continuous
deployment of this application without
having to lose state we'll worry about
consistency and if I have enough time at
the end I'll go ahead and do a live
deployment of one of my own kubernetes
clusters that I just set up specifically
for you guys so why kubernetes will look
like about half the rooms already using
it so the first point that each that
it's ubiquitous appears to be true but
the reason why I tend to lean towards
kubernetes for my applications is
because it's one of the only tools out
there that has a really good first party
con
except for how to manage stateful
applications docker swarm by contrast
does not have a mechanism like that so
that's one of the sort of weaknesses of
some of the other orchestration
platforms out there but on top of that
kubernetes has a really rich ecosystem
built around it you're gonna see in a
minute here that I'm using Azure
kubernetes service but Amazon and Google
also have their own kubernetes services
that they offer to developers and on top
of that there's got to be at least a
dozen turnkey kubernetes vendors for
building on-premise systems too so if
you work in healthcare or finance or
government or defense or whatever
there's plenty of different options you
can use to make sure kubernetes works in
an environment that suits you and your
organization's needs
now as for why a jacuz Benetti service
the long story short is it's probably
the easiest one of these environments to
set up that can actually give you a
little bit of scale it only took me a
few minutes to do it right before this
talk so I recommend that as sort of a
set of training wheels for learning how
kubernetes works now a couple of core
concepts in kubernetes kubernetes is
fundamentally an orchestration platform
we're just designed to do is if you have
multiple host machines that can all run
docker containers that house your
application and maybe some of the other
pieces of infrastructure you might need
like monitoring or tracing tools
kubernetes abstracts the fact that there
might be many pieces of hardware all
involved in trying to service those
requests it gives you sort of a flat
surface you can deploy onto and
kubernetes will figure out which boxes
should on which boxes should each
application be deployed and tries to do
that to guarantee the maximum degree of
fault tolerance and availability inside
your system so for instance if you
deployed three replicas of one of your
applications kubernetes will spread that
out across multiple hosts
rather than clump them all together on a
single box and then lastly kubernetes is
highly configurable you can go ahead and
for instance specify that what an
application needs to be restarted or
deployed you can go ahead and say you
know what I actually want you to add a
new instance of this node before you
begin replacing the older nodes give me
some more Headroom rather than replacing
existing nodes right away it has a lot
of different knobs and dials you can use
to configure your deployments and that's
really useful in environments where you
have a large amount of traffic you want
to go ahead and make sure you have
enough buffer room that any event you
start doing a deployment you don't lose
some of the capacity you need to stay
available and this is fundamentally what
sort of a kubernetes deployment might
look like in production you might have
let's say three hosts three different
machines all running the kubernetes
agents on it and they're the ones
managing the kubernetes pods which are
the little units that how's your docker
containers and most kubernetes services
will be totally hidden from the network
aqua dot remote and aqua dot cluster for
instance should never be publicly
exposed over the network directly
instead you might want to go ahead and
expose your kubernetes service through
the public endpoints you define on
something like a web browser or RabbitMQ
ingestion service any number of
different tools that can provide you
with robust security and authorization
mechanisms akka dot cluster is just
infrastructure it's not meant to provide
all that for you it's meant to get
messages very rapidly from point A to
point B this is fundamentally one of the
ployed sort of kubernetes architecture
might look like in our case we're just
exposing a load balancer service so do
some round-robin load balancing around
our web application which is what feeds
data into this particular application I
built and then on as your IKS I took a
screenshot here of what all the fully
provisioned infrastructure looks like in
Azure
in fact one thing I'm gonna do real
quickly here is I'm gonna change my
screen just a second here that looks
beautiful doesn't it all right give me
just a moment okay
now what I'm going to go ahead and do
real briefly is I'm gonna pull up my
live running cluster here I think I need
to here we go so if I take a look here
on screen this is what my live running
kubernetes cluster looks like it's
literally just this little clump of
stuff right here but under the cover is
what that IKS cluster really is is what
you see in my presentation might go back
it's a series of disks and virtual
machines and a network and security
groups Azure goes and creates all the
infrastructure for you under the covers
so you don't have to figure out how to
do this on your own if I had to go and
build an environment like this on my own
probably would have taken me like two
weeks to do it instead with Azure
Community Service I can get this spun up
in a matter of minutes instead that's
why I strongly encourage you if you're
looking to learn how kubernetes works
IKS is a really good way to get started
now some key terms for kubernetes in the
context of akkad Anette first is a pod a
pod represents a single unit of work
inside kubernetes and typically one pod
houses one docker container it's
technically possible for multiple
containers to run inside one pod so for
instance if you're using a cadet net and
New Relic
and you want to use New Relic for
monitoring you might deploy nude relic
as a sidecar Pauw a sidecar docker
container inside your pod although
that's kind of unusual though the really
big term that we want to remember as
academia developers is a stateful set
that's the mechanism we're going to use
for deploying akka dotnet services to
kubernetes because stateful sets are
identified as kubernetes as nodes that
have to migrate state from point A to
point B so to believe what kubernetes
will do during a deployment against the
stateful set is they'll go ahead and
rotate your nodes out one at a time and
they'll provide a long grace period for
changing those nodes too and then lastly
we have the concept of a service a
service is how you go and expose your
pods inside the network inside
kubernetes
so some services can be exposed publicly
like a load balancer or an ingress
service most services inside a cadet are
headless meaning they can only be
accessed inside the kubernetes
environment so in the case of our little
sample here in fact you know what let me
go ahead and get my mouse out all of
these the containers here contain a
cadet net services and they're all
networked together inside the kubernetes
network the only pawns that are exposed
directly to the outside is the service
that houses our web pods it goes and
allows us to route traffic on port 80 to
the asp.net core process that I set up
and a steep will set if I want to do a
deployment what'll end up happening is
I'll go ahead and tell kubernetes I want
you to change the version of the docker
image that's currently running inside
here I want you to move from image
number zero point two four to zero point
two five and that's gonna be what
triggers the deployment inside
kubernetes so what kubernetes will do is
it'll go ahead and tart kill this first
container it'll say okay I'm gonna have
you gracefully shut down and it'll give
it enough time to hand over its state to
someone else so I manually programmed
this specific application to give it
about 40 seconds to hand over its state
from point A to point B which is more
than enough time probably only need
realistically more like 10 seconds in
order to do it once that container is
shut down kubernetes will then replace
it with the updated version using the
new docker image tag that we had before
and then once that container boots up
and its liveness check passes meaning
that kubernetes is able to tell the
application started correctly it'll move
on to replacing the next one of the
replicas inside the cluster somewhere
and so you can see we'll go ahead and
gradually one by one replace all the
nodes for this service and so they're
all running this specific version of the
docker image that I want now the
methodology that we're going to use for
doing these live deployments is that all
applications that use akka dotnet will
be deployed as stateful sets since state
is fundamental to how akka dot cluster
works and essential for building these
real-time applications we're looking to
develop all internal akka dot cluster
functionality will be exposed as AI
cluster IP service otherwise known as a
headless service in kubernetes and all
external functionality can be exposed as
a load balancer or an ingress service
which allows you to go ahead and punch a
hole to the external Network and let
traffic in and peda bridge command which
you didn't get a chance to talk about
today we will use that for some node
exits and then deployments and rollbacks
or basically doing upgrades or anything
else are always done by changing the
docker image tag now I'm gonna skip that
real quick now I'm gonna do a little bit
of a demo here before I take some
questions and by the way I'll be
available right outside room five if you
have questions you want to ask one on
one but this URL on screen here will
take you to a set of step-by-step
tutorials were created for learning how
to work with akka dot cluster kubernetes
docker step-by-step so it takes about a
couple days to do maybe depends on how
fast you are but I would go ahead and
recommend following up with that if you
want to learn how to use all these tools
one step at a time we just published
this on May 30th so it's brand-new now
but I wanted the show real briefly
before we before we depart ways here is
what I have on screen right here is the
output from the kubernetes command line
interface called coop cuddle in fact you
know what I'll do I'll clear my screen
real quick I'm gonna go ahead and get
all the resources inside my kubernetes
namespace I set up on Azure kubernetes
service and this would be a bad time for
the internet to go down but I don't
think it will no I should be good all
right there we go I just got a list of
all my services back that are running
inside my kubernetes cluster apparently
my jäger node Jager is a distributed
tracing tool ran out of memory and got
evicted by kubernetes so we'll go ahead
and pour one out for Jager a little bit
later but my akka dotnet cluster is just
fine I have a bunch of nodes that are
still running and I have about two
copies of
what you'll also notice is the set of
services I have running inside
kubernetes right here some of them are
publicly available my 3 load balancer
services and they have external IPS that
are open to the internet created by the
azure kubernetes service so if I go for
instance to this IP address forty
seventy four to forty eight ten if I go
and pull that up I believe that is my
application right here that's doing this
this application is basically a fake
stock market is what's going on and I'm
getting real-time price and volume
notifications so yeah there you go
so we get new price notifications about
every ten seconds we batch them inside
the system so you can see my web app is
doing this to give you an example that
I'm not totally full of it here I'm
gonna do a live deployment for one of
our stateful nodes that produces this
data and you'll see that the stream of
data we receive here does not get
interrupted so I'm gonna do that by
going to Azure pipeline's here I'm going
to grab my trade processor my trade
processor is the node that's actually
running what's called the order book
system matching by trades and sell
trades together in order to produce up
matches essentially I'm gonna go ahead
and do a roll back to a previous version
of my docker container this is gonna run
that Kubb cuddle command under the
covers here so I'm gonna pull this up
actually know what I need to create a
new release my bad you create release
I'm gonna go ahead and pick my
deployment step deploy to Kate's I'm
gonna go ahead and grab the version I
want to deploy I'll do 0.2 and I'm gonna
go ahead and kick that off now this is a
manual release so I have to go ahead and
check a button letting as your pipelines
know that I'm not insane I'm gonna go
ahead and do that here
let's see me get rid of that click
deploy there we go
so that should run any minute let's see
what do you say all I need to scroll
down and confirm it oh there you go
thank you see we've got some experience
as your pipelines users in the audience
I see alright thank you
all right so that's queued up for
deployment and this appointments very
fast all we're doing is telling
kubernetes to change the version of the
docker image that we're using all right
in progress
hooray all right and that should be done
in a second here okay looks like it's
finished good now if I go to coop cuddle
and I go ahead and I say get all again
what we should see is some of the pods
for that trader service should be
getting swapped out now all right here
we go so take a look at this we are in a
container creating state here this means
that the old version of that pod was
already terminated by kubernetes and is
now being recreated in place and you'll
see in a moment here the lifespan of
this node is already set to 6 seconds
the other nodes been active for an hour
meaning that one hasn't been touched yet
by kubernetes if I go and run my query
again here let me do that real fast all
right if I do that you'll notice both of
these nodes have now been replaced so
they're both about 30 seconds old and if
I go back to my screen here my akka CQRS
pricing system I should go ahead and see
another price update in a matter of
seconds here just a moment there we go
got some more pricing information going
in the reason why that was able to work
is one of the order book nodes when it
shut down hands off its state to the
next order book node and then when that
node had to shut down it handed it back
to the new node that just got upgraded
so they kind of ping-pong their state
back and forth and persisted everything
to MongoDB under the covers so that's it
for my presentation today I'll go ahead
and pull up the URL
more time here if you want to learn how
to do this step by step please go here
otherwise thank you very much for
attending my talk today and I'd love to
talk to some of you outside if you have
questions thank you very much
[Applause]